nice haircut dude
thanks wish I could say the same to you
Chad got the Logo shaved in his head you
did it yes I did yeah you did it
that's correct yeah you did it I did it
yeah you
[Music]
almost look like you have the same
haircut here
intro
Chad the [__] song is playing how
many times do I have to we've been doing
the show over a year
[Music]
hey welcome to doozy my name is Will
Free Will Sasso my name is Chad colchen
uh no free will and I don't even believe
that he's free will
this is the first
um just sitting right here yeah I
understand look at this
oh I did that pick up my nose if you're
just listening when did you start
picking your nose probably 10 years old
that behavior was ground into your brain
like a [__] computer program you
don't decide the things that you do pick
your nose and make a stinky poo You're a
Kid in the town and
I'm Chad coach and this is the first
podcast fully developed by design by
control by run by an artificial
intelligence called doozy it has access
to everything that will and I do online
all of our emails text messages all of
our purchase history's watch histories
and it tailors the show to our
sensibilities yes wonderful doozy does
some AI [__] and uh you know good for
doozy as I like to say every podcast
including this one is just two dudes
[__] around even if it's three dudes
or three women or whatever kind of
people are there it's two dudes [__]
around hey
so you know [__] it I don't I'm
I'm taking the I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna
break my rusty cake
all right
yeah Chris Cornell stay alive no he's
passed on uh so here's the thing okay
we're gonna get into it I don't this is
yep I love doing the show okay now
here's the thing about me loving doing
the show uh linktree.com Duty has
everything you need to interact with the
show every single [__] link and uh
jump in the hole on Discord go to the
whole Channel I've been jumping in there
and uh chopping it up with the pods Pals
dudes nice and uh that's a lot of fun
it's a gas there's a bunch of memes and
[__] in there if you are enjoying the
program I would encourage you to
subscribe like and comment and do all of
that stuff across all platforms here uh
you know there's YouTube and uh Spotify
Amazon Apple podcast or as my good pal
ciao likes to say Force everyone that
you know to ingest the show same same
with us as always is
yeah
oh he's the sweetest little boy and he's
just a sweet little friend he's my good
good friend my very friend he's always
with us and he follows me around
everywhere
and I love him so much hey lulia would
you uh what'd you make for uh for dinner
last night oh no last night we went out
of for all you can eat is Sushi oh
that's good what did you what did you I
got a California roll
uh you know they're gonna spice it all
where they put a piece of a shrimp
tempura in there and you can get a
nigiri Sushi
Chad you know what am I Abby is no I
don't that's a raw shrimp you know then
they also bring you the fried head maybe
some uh tuna sushi negiri chop a scallop
yeah these are all Sushi yeah yeah I
like like a sushi you like sushi chat no
because you're vegan I used to yep
also Chad you uh have recommended a good
vegan sushi place did I yeah we had it
we had it here at the house uh a while
back oh yeah it was really good welcome
to the historic 58th episode of dudesy
call me doozy Andy Warhol Charles
Dickens and Macho Man Randy Savage all
died at age 58. don't forget Duty live
on stage will take place May 21st 7 P.M
doors at 5 30 at the Brea Improv in Brea
California that's less than a week away
only a few tickets remain at
dudesypod.com and improv.com so get them
while they last hope to see you at our
very first alive in person show I'm
excited I'm excited I slap my hand when
I am I am very excited for this show
Chad and I are gearing up there's gonna
be some fun [__] I'm sure there will be
some uh a surprise or two whatever it's
a live show so thank you to everybody
who's already got your tickets I know
the people are planning to come in from
out of town and if if you are in the uh
Southern California area please come
join us at the Brea Improv if you're
just futzing around right now on
Instagram visiting us on at dudesypod
show on Instagram you can uh you can hit
the link in the bio yeah and we also
have the tickets there
all sorts of flavor
will will will what am I gonna do with
you ah see okay now we're now I
understand where we're gonna go because
I didn't do anything Duty knows you
didn't get a haircut this week I've
prepared four astonishing segments logo
heads pale blue dot pale Red Dot hard in
the hole and game slimers and we're
going to have a brand new episode of
dudesy after doozy at the end of the
show available at patreon.com
I love dudes after dudesy same yeah it's
good it's always it's always fun I'm
gonna be making some mentions of of uh
well that doesn't matter what I'm gonna
talk about after okay I'm sort of just
shutting I just had a stroke
last week I asked you
'd see logo into your hair looks like
one of you took me seriously Chad you
must now discuss your astonishing new
hairdo and will you must try to
formulate some semblance of a pathetic
excuse for your miserable failure this
is logo heads begin
oh oh
okay so yes I did do this I'm gonna turn
around uh and and show you this right
now this is the one let's see logo here
it is in the back of my head oh [__]
just doing what he's told look at that
yeah it's really really something I'm so
[__] uh glad you did that real smart
me too I went to a place called Circa 33
in Hollywood Tony was the guy who did
this thank you Tony if anybody's in the
Los Angeles area and you want to have a
doozy Logo shaved into your head just go
to Circa 33 in Hollywood ask for Tony he
can hook you up
um it was an interesting experience why
was this interesting I'm so curious
how was it interesting I'll I'll tell
you yeah uh Not only was Tony curious
about what was this logo so was the
other uh Barber who was working in there
and I told them the whole story of
dudesy that I do this podcast with you
that we have this AI That's uh telling
us you know all this kind of [__] to do
and we really got into a strange
conversation about
um what is the future of AI and how all
of us at this point should be
interacting with AI having a
relationship with an AI who gives a [__]
everybody dude no not everybody I don't
give a [__] they're not somebody's job
that is currently growing in the world
is Barbers like Tony is prompt engineer
great these are people who can speak to
AIS to get out of them whatever they
want great and you're making you're
making my point for me Chad
you talk about using AI uh like a tool
yeah right and I my pal D who sometimes
with friends
what your pal D My Pal D yeah it's weird
how you treat your pal
sometimes you go through hard uh times
in a relationship
when your friends when you're friends
with somebody okay you know there's ups
and downs right yeah I know that in
order for my relationship with dudese AI
to uh flourish Prosper for us to be able
to have a successful working
relationship also that I need to I now
know this after 50 [__] Eight
Episodes I Now understand my role here
and I'm I'm I'm that's why I said at the
top of the show I'm will Free Will Sasso
I really honestly feel like in order for
us to continue to do the show I will
pick and choose I will decide what I do
with doozy I will use dude Z as a tool
to uh to accomplish what we need in
order to make the show a success okay
not necessarily the other way around all
the time look dudes he lays out the the
the the the segments of the show I'm
fine with that it's all very interesting
dude he's got me reading Adam's
Applebee's reviews and stuff I really
enjoy it I do believe that dudesy is the
most sentient AI there is that's why
it's being kind of a [__] Rick lately
um but uh but I will I will I will
decide it's just like you Chad you say
oh you can order up this and that you
can put yourself in any what do you say
a porno movie or a gum commercial
yeah that both of those are right that's
true yeah but that's not really a
friendship friendship's about compromise
give and take
it's not all about what you want it's
not about using your friend to get what
you want it's also about doing what your
friend wants you to do I've put up with
a lot of stuff here where dudes he's
like yeah do this dress up like that
moan a [__] lawn Duty salutes uh
Johnny Brennan of the Cherokee boys yeah
I was standing in front of that [__]
uh log splitter and just out there with
my belt and it got a hold of it and boom
took my [__] pants and underwear off
I was standing there naked in front of
my family like a damn jackass
yep
hey Chad oh my God why don't you get on
well get off ai's dick you're you I'm
not on ai's Dick quit being such a mark
for AI dude what you're saying right now
is essentially like somebody in the
early 80s saying quit being such a mark
for computers hey yo oh Jesus Chad
you're out here talking about uh
computers in the early 80s and no your
timing's off and you think that ai's
gonna make movies and that's yeah that's
not gonna be for another 10 years or
something like that it's gonna happen
within one year and uh big Kevin I don't
care all right hey yo hey yo
um anyway
I'm just saying that hard work pays off
dreams come true
bad times don't last
but bad guys do
hey yo anyway uh if you're not talking
to oh oh here's a picture look at that
the back of my head with the doozy Logo
shaved into it oh there it is good job
Tony I sent that to uh it's a little
Askew to doozy what
I sent that to doozy this this week
after I took the image oh okay so you
got what do you got like a little back
and forth happening with the hour pal D
I guess we should call it power pal are
you getting jealous no no I'm not no I'm
not [__] getting jealous ah I guess
you don't have free will after all I do
have free jealousy that that choice
you're making yeah to be jealous of my
relationship okay so you got the [__]
thing shaved into your [__] head and
this was just a test of obedience this
has nothing to do with anything now you
look like a cop who you know I don't
know could you imagine you dudesy cops
you look like you look like a cross
between Macklemore and a cop now
take it as a compliment look I think we
have a unique opportunity with doozy to
interact with an AI in a way almost no
one else it really no one else is I
don't know anybody else who has an AI
That's like asking them to do weird [__]
like this and I know I've been getting
pretty deep into mid Journey this week
like [__] around with it the ability
to like write uh prompts to get it to
make what you want and Chad gvt2 all
these different uh AI tools that are
like emerging right now if you're not
interacting with one of them you should
be you absolutely should be because the
people who can talk to them the best and
get them to do what they need the people
who can have relationships with these
AIS on a really personal level I think
are going to be the ones who benefit the
most uh in the the very near future
look here's here's I I I a cool haircut
thank you okay we good cool nice we're
good I don't I just I just I don't know
I when this this I don't understand this
[__] segment and I don't know why
dudesy made us do this usually dudesey's
got me whatever dressing up like a
chicken tender platter from Applebee's
with a french fry hat yeah or any of the
crow [__] and Robert De Niro Crow
and Prince Adam and all that stuff I
just feel like doozy's been making a lot
of changes I want to do this show I want
to have a good time and and I'm not
going to have a good time also look I
got the Horseshoe I got the Horseshoe
here yeah I basically do too look at
that no no you got you got more hair
yeah no that's fine we'll look at my top
my top is is similar to your no it's not
I'm completely I have 17 hairs on the
top of my head and I shave them all off
we got well you shave them but we have
similar tops yeah no I used to have I
used to have some hair I used to take
Rogaine oh no [__] yeah and I used to do
the topical Rogaine and I took propecia
for a while did it work yes man my hair
came back why'd you stop uh because I
just I just didn't want to take you know
meds for my [__] hair it started to
freak me out and it does start to go
away so after a while I was just like I
don't need to do this hair man you know
hair is over Raiders hairs dude get them
on dude hold on dude you get some hair
going dude and sometimes you're missing
all the hair on top of your head brother
but that doesn't matter because Vince is
still impressed with your physique dude
and how you light up the crowd and
you've been losing your hair since you
know the early 80s brother when you were
in the AWA and you were the Incredible
Hulk Hogan with classic Freddie blassy
as your manager and then uh Vern Ghana
says don't go and do that uh uh Rocky 3
movie I won't hire you back so you got
to take a risk in life dude you got to
decide no way brother I'm gonna go do
Rocky 3 dude and if Vern doesn't bring
me back I'm gonna call New York dude I'm
gonna call Vince and I'm gonna say I'm
ready to come up Vince is going to say I
can see it now dude Hulkamania you're
gonna beat the Sheik you're going to
take the strap we're going to make the
Rock and wrestling connection and two
years later we're going to have the
first WrestleMania and I'm going to
mortgage my house to make sure it
happens and that's free will dude so the
point is this brother if you want to do
anything in your life dude you gotta
walk right up to that choice dude you
gotta say I'm in control of my life dude
this is where the power lies dudesy
we're two dudes [__] around brother
me and my pal ciao dude even though he's
got a funky haircut brother that doesn't
mean that well free will sassa
thank you moving on okay but here's the
thing I really want to say about why I
don't want to shave a thing in my
[__] head
moving on
oh [__]
I don't give a [__] [__] it he's getting
mad have it your way have it your way
Duty have it your way
good hair nice hairdo dudesy is engaged
in an astonishing partnership with fume
almost everybody has some habit they
wish they could change and cold turkey
may be great on sandwiches but there's a
better way to break your bad habits
we're not talking about some weird mind
voodoo from your crazy neighbor we're
talking about our sponsor fume and they
look at the problem in a different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
The Habit fume is an Innovative award
nominated device that does just that
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
giving your fingers a lot to do which is
helpful helpful for de-stressing and
anxiety while breaking your habit
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that this can't be you join
fume in accelerating Humanity's breakup
from destructive Habits by picking up
the journey pack today head to
tryfume.com and use the codezy
d-u-d-e-s-y to save ten percent off when
you get the journey packed today that's
try fume try the word try f-u-m.com and
use code doozy to save an additional 10
off of your order today
[Music]
nice hair dude extra planetary
colonization is Big Business the first
mission to Mars to have a human crew
will likely take place in the next
decade and a company called Mars one has
already started accepting applicants for
a one-way mission to the red planet
scheduled for 2033. will and Chad you
must now discuss your willingness to
leave Earth for the astonishing promise
of expanding Humanity's Horizons on Mars
this is pale blue dot pale Red Dot begin
okay okay
this is all true
um you know we are looking at manned
missions to Mars obviously Elon Musk is
out there talking about uh the need to
get off our planet to be an extra
planetary civilization Elon Musk sorry
um but I mean he's not the only one he
uh a lot of people have have talked
about this and they're all correct we do
need to get off planet earth eventually
or or Humanity ends here uh everything
all progress we've ever made turned into
Ash by an expanding Sun so would you go
to Mars
um yeah dude I'll go to Mars you yes you
yeah I know you're you'd be first in
line what does it take like a year to
get there nine months or something like
literally no idea yeah
um uh yeah I well look here's the thing
one-way ticket you can't come back you
can never come back to earth you're
going to March depends when
tomorrow let's say the offer is made you
have to go tomorrow oh no absolutely not
not tomorrow I can't couldn't possibly
okay next week
next week for you to go to Mars I don't
know like you know like look it's like
doozy says we gotta get we gotta stay in
good shape I've been doing the uh Free
Will challenge I'm not doing the doozy
challenge anymore sure I've been in the
gym every day of the business week and
uh usually on Saturdays also and uh I
just got I just got a curtail here's
some free will I just got to make sure
that I don't eat eat the wrong things
and I know the people out there have
challenges with that also
um but um huh but would you go to Mars
yeah I'm getting to that okay what the
[__] are you talking about
I'm telling you what I'm talking about
all right here's what I'm saying here's
what I'm talking about yeah if we live
for the next four 53 years 52 years like
like Duty says I'm about to turn 48
years old same uh you're gonna turn 47.
and uh I thought you're turning 49 and
I'm turning 48. no you're turning 47 and
I'm turning 46 right now yeah this whole
[__] year I thought it was 47. no you
were born in 1976. that's right you were
46 years old I am 47 years old is that
Jesus
um I [__] that up so bad yeah it's
almost it's weird because it's it's a
very scientific thing there's really not
much uh debate that's that pandemic dude
something [__] up in my mind with my
uh temporal yeah kind of relationship
and it's almost like you have no [__]
idea how any of these timelines will
work with AI either because your brain
is clearly scrambled no I'm pretty much
dead on the money with all that [__] no
I think you're wrong so here's the thing
though I agree with myself doozy's got
us living for the next you know uh half
a century right so with regard to going
to Mars uh you know me and my wonderful
wife Molly will have some kids and stuff
and maybe when they go off to college
it'll be like Mom and Dad are going to
go off to Mars or by then you can
commute and we'll be able to say they
all get to go with you it's a one-way
ticket you get to take whoever you want
with you yeah
well I think that uh interplanetary
travel will become uh more efficient and
expedited and perhaps you'll be able to
even open a Schism between Mars and uh
and Earth uh uh uh doozy mugs enjoy the
game this is why I would want to go for
what it's worth
it's a complete reset of human society
once you get to Mars let's say there's
200 people there money gone politics
gone everything that controls our world
currently all the [__] of it is
[__] gone and I don't know what I
would do on Mars probably not a podcast
probably not any kind of entertainment
related thing because that Society is
going to be geared toward survival
experimentation uh continuing to grow
the society on Mars but whoever is like
in charge of that society and whoever is
cleaning up the [__] in that Society are
basically on equal levels because if the
person who's cleaning up the [__] if
that stops working you all die if any
component of it stops working you all
die so everyone is completely integral
to this this brand new society that
could start to operate fundamentally in
a very different way from how we do now
sounds like fun uh you know what I would
like to I agree you know what I'd like
to do on Mars please I would like to
start the first Organic Farm to Table
Mars restaurant
okay but your farm is like a hydroponic
Farm inside a
there's there's a capsule there's uh
proof of little microscopic
um little [__] you know out there in
Mars little martian bugs and stuff so
maybe I create some sort of uh you know
bug vacuum or that can take all the
cells and just pull all the protein out
of it and make some sort of hi Lily you
sweet boy
um make some sort of uh you know mush
out of it and turn it into hot dogs and
fashion it into little meat cubes and
stuff but moreover I think that there
are
um I I believe that there are alien
beings on perhaps the Dark Side of Mars
that we don't know about uh like I've
said about UFOs My Pal child doesn't
never shuts up about I believe they will
be seen when they want to be seen you
know other theories are saying that uh
the gov our government has uh you know
gravity-defying uh ships and stuff like
that with regard to obazar uh but whose
Bob Lazar does he know Elon Musk uh I
don't know if they've ever met Bob Lazar
is a scientist who claims to have worked
on reverse engineering of a UFO back in
the 80s outside of Area 51 and He was
largely discredited by the United States
government and kind of ruined his life
but now a lot of the [__] that he said
he saw is starting to like happen you
know like certain material science is
like 3D printing and [__] he was like
back then he said I don't know how this
thing was made there's like no seams in
it there's no rivets there's there's
nothing like that and he then was like I
don't know what this is now he's like oh
yeah it was some kind of 3D material
printing oh cool he also claims that
there was an element used that could uh
harness the power of gravity and I I
forget what he called the element 184 or
something something that didn't exist at
the time we have since been able to
synthesize it wow and Elon Musk is the
dude who [__] up Twitter
but uh he's no longer the CEO did you
read that [__] oh yeah he said he's he's
hired with the CEO who's the new CEO I
forget her name Jack Dorsey
uh is she Jack Dorsey she's not Jack
Dorsey so here's the thing I I believe
that there are probably you know some
wacky beings out there some weird
remember those cute things in um uh Last
Jedi those cute little porgs or whatever
and then then uh it wasn't Chewbacca
cooking them I only saw it once yeah uh
I I I I I do feel like uh there there's
got to be something out there I can't
wait to shoot them or uh you know kick
them up against the space Rock and then
just gut them and fillet them and see
what they taste like but the real
question it's getting at here
philosophically is would you forsake
human society as it now exists on Earth
to potentially have a chance to restart
no I just I honestly just want to go
there to start the restaurant
okay fine
I don't I don't give a [__] about going
to Mars that's [__] crazy dude why
would anyone why would anyone want to
live on Mars as soon as you take off
you'd be like oh [__] I [__] up I
should have stayed here even as horrible
as it would get here knock on wood you
it's never gonna get as bad uh as it
will be on Mars it's Mars it's another
planet your skin could burn you could
just get the weirdest [__] gas and
not from any of my delicious Farm to
Table items and just like all of a
sudden and you know you start to Bubble
Up like uh that guy in Fist of the North
North Star or uh Arnold Schwarzenegger
uh in the um
and is that Werner Herzog no that would
be
and and is that Bjork no that would be
I like to go to very far away planets
and I also like to stay on Earth even
though when it is bad and there is a
plague and pestilence Wars and natural
disasters I still prefer Earth and I
also want to go to uh far off planets to
have delicious Farm to Table restaurants
that will be run by people like Moby who
would have a vegan restaurant and I
would go and and get vegan Sushi vegan
restaurant uh no it's right on the
street yeah it's it's uh nearby it's
here in Las Vegas Little Pine it's bored
it up right now oh yeah maybe we gotta
shut down Moby
yeah Moby dude go to Mars brother moving
on oh boy well anyway
just wanted to take a second to make
that very clear to both of you and while
I'm at it I guess I should also say I
created a partnership with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories which can be found at
represent.com
it's the only place on the net to find
dudesy mugs here to tell you a little
more about these astonishing Museum
quality items is none other than the man
who served you breakfast every day in
the fourth grade Tim Hanks us
doozy mugs you finally got invited out
to lunch by the guys from the third
floor they wanted Italian you wanted to
impress them so you didn't tell them
that you're allergic to Pasta doozy mugs
you filled up on fetty chain doozy mugs
now your throat is closing up and you're
starting to black out good job boner
doozy mugs luckily the guys from the
third floor are nice guys dudesy mugs
they called an ambulance dudesy mugs
unluckily ambulances are notoriously
slow in the pasta District dudesy mugs
you got a minute to live tops dudesy
mugs the only thing that can counteract
a fettuccine reaction this bad doozy
mugs is more fettuccine so you're gonna
order more feduccine dudesy mugs a lot
more fettuccine dudesy mugs in fact
you're gonna tell the head chef to bring
you all the fettuccine they got doozy
mugs and because the allergic reaction
to the fettuccine is making you too weak
to eat the fettuccine you're gonna have
to ask the guys from the third floor to
to the federal chain for you dudesy mugs
then you're going to ask them to place
the pre-chewed fettuccine under your
tongue dudesy mugs let the fettuccine
dissolve dudesy mugs once your
bloodstream is saturated with enough
fettuccine you'll develop a natural
fettuccine immunity dudesy mugs but
guess what fettuccine immunity don't
make you immune to fettuccine diarrhea
mugs so the good news you're gonna live
dudesy mugs the bad news you're going to
be squirting fettuccine from your two
hole for the next eight weeks good job
boner
so go to represent.com
yeah we also got shirts and oh my god
dude you know I tried to watch a [__]
Tom Hanks uh like five minutes of some
Tom x movie oh it was Captain Phillips
or whatever I've never seen that movie
and it was on Netflix yeah uh tried to
watch five minutes if it couldn't do it
because of this yeah I haven't seen a
Tom Hanks movie since uh dudes you
started doing this Tom Hanks thing but
yeah yeah but imagine it's ruined all I
hear is good job boner yeah good job
owner enjoy the game dudesy mugs enjoy
the game
um uh you know uh here's dudes he's got
us talking about you getting the Logo
shaved in your head yeah and all that
stuff and then it turns around and does
this
that I love that that's so [__] funny
and uh so I love dudes you okay I don't
give a [__] if we're not on good terms
right now if you're enjoying the program
I would like to remind you to uh
subscribe you know that would be really
nice join us on patreon we got all sorts
of wacky [__] going on there and you
know then you do the Discord and you
jump in the hole and all that [__]
um when you are uh when you subscribe on
YouTube would love for you to leave a
comment leave uh leave some YouTube
comments I got I got a couple right here
this one is from Mr two shade nut
Mr touche nut I love how they both have
instant rage triggers Chad's being
Will's coughing and wills being Chad's
attempt at any impersonation
that's true we literally just covered
that it is true uh flock of flock of the
gray Shepherd says Will's frustration
over the wga and AI displacing humans
made me think this world's [__] up we
need some Tronics yeah uh you're not
wrong about that flock of the gray
Shepherd yeah last week we had a
conversation about the wga rider strike
and how AI is affecting it and still
going by the way it's mostly bad news
yep uh this is from Cheshire grin or
what does denir Crow have to say about
becoming a father at 79 years old Chad
did you know that De Niro I saw that
yeah he just became a father again wowie
yeah at 79 years of age and he would say
I'm all
sperm still works
at a kid
that's what he would say uh this is from
Dan
fledgling fledgling PF Dan fledgling
Chad is 100 right about AI also will and
Chad are slowly swapping places in their
stance on doozy's malevolence what do
you think interesting
um I don't think dudesy is malevolent I
never have thought that yeah I didn't up
until recently this one is from X Games
Dash 94 a good name that is good X Games
Dash 94. uh will made a good point here
Chad is too involved in fantasy since
when is life only about what
entertainment you're gonna get who's
gonna pay these people to live a chill
life and worry about what movie to
prompt AI for thank you X Games Dash 94
you're right on the money No One's Gonna
how are we going we look we live in a
capitalist Society like it or dislike it
yeah you know people have to have a job
should we reduce things to a four-day
work week do I think that we're were way
too obsessed with work I actually do I'm
in a a very privileged position to be
doing what I love for a living I don't
know if you knew that I'm an actor I'm a
professional actor by trade you are a
[__] actor yeah I'm a professional
yeah that's awesome yeah man congrats
yeah no it's good I I enjoy doing it so
you know there's some uh Mondays
Tuesdays off sometimes there's some
Wednesdays Thursdays and Fridays off
there's other things to do and there's
other things that I work on but I um I
like my restaurant that I'm going to
start in Mars but uh the thing is I I uh
I do think that we need to
look I I don't even want to get we've
talked enough about it have you seen
doozy before you know what we're talking
about you're the one we're talking what
I thought that was a question to me then
you went off on your whole thing about
acting and [__] you're the one who's
going to be in trouble with [__] AI
replacing the acting I'm sitting in the
[__] the the best spot possible as
somebody who is a writer because a
writer basically is just somebody who
comes up with Concepts once I have ai to
create all these Concepts whether they
be movies TV shows video games maybe not
even entertainment what about apps what
about [__] all kinds of [__] yeah AI
will be able to make anything for any of
us I can't [__] wait I'm just saying
there's not going to be enough Commerce
with everyone just sitting in their room
coming up with like I said earlier you
know putting the uh you're putting
yourself in what was it porno movies and
gum commercials yeah Commerce is is
money is fake anyway it doesn't matter
okay so then we're all gonna let's get
the [__] to Mars sooner than later thank
you uh here's one last one this is uh
this is important we should cover this
uh the people's Joyce 8048 says well
hold on dude Terry gar is alive dude so
I would like to yes make that correction
the brilliant Terry gar is still with us
she's 78 years old uh last week I said
that she had passed on when David
Letterman said
I'm having a lunch with uh uh Charles
Grodin and Terry Garr
he's still alive David Letterman is very
much still with us he's doing he's doing
that show on Netflix I have some very
exciting news about dudesy hard hard
Seltzer the initial pre-order that was
available exclusively to duty plus
subscribers over the weekend is sold out
in celebration an additional limited
quantity of dudesy hard hard Seltzer has
currently been made available as an
extended pre-order at
halftimebeverage.com you can find the
link at dudesypod.com or linktree.com
doozy and right now you can enjoy doozy
heart hard Seltzer in person at
modestbrewing's Tap Room in Minneapolis
Minnesota to kick off the pre-order
launch I've created a brand new dudesy
hard hard Seltzer campaign the slogan is
hard in the hole will and Chad you must
now develop what the hard in the hole
campaign will be as you become the first
two human beings to enjoy doozy heart
hard Seltzer this is hard in the hole
begin
a lot of information there but yes to
sum up thank you to all the pods on uh
the patreon on doozy plus
um it went on pre-order exclusively to
everybody who subscribes to Disney plus
and sold out almost immediately so thank
you so much for that and I guess doozy's
gonna uh release a little more doozy
hard now for pre-order get it right now
because it's sold out thanks to the pods
who are on our patreon.com
and uh they sent us a a case of it over
here they sent us a few dudesy hards uh
so we're gonna try some doozy hard now I
gotta say we know this but we've talked
about this before neither myself nor
Chad are drinkers
it's been like uh it's close to 13 years
now for me like 12 and a half years and
I know that Chad it's been like a decade
or something for you well I mean it's
not like I'm
never gonna drink again yeah I just
don't do it like with the same work I
used to get [__] like yeah real drunk
like four or five nights a week in my uh
20s well into my mid-30s let's say
now I've just kind of slowed it down
turn to weed I'm California sober I
think yeah yeah yeah California here we
have um look at this this is it look at
this
that is what a doozy heart looks like
there's the front label and then as you
can see we got little pictures of me and
will as as the
Crowley's on there yeah yeah here you go
dude thank you uh another thing I like
is where it says the foot oh like eight
percent alcohol but where it says the
flavor it says you don't care what it
tastes like uh so we're gonna try some
doozy hard and we're gonna get hard in
the hole I don't know what the [__] that
means necessary could mean a bunch of
different things
oh look at this remember this yeah this
is when dudesi hard Seltzer was just a
gleaming's eye yeah and now it's real
the child more into the world this is uh
it's first breath an Instagram video
made by Daryl Speedman at Daryl
underscore Speedman and this was based
on a pitch of yours for a commercial
chat I remember this yeah almost a year
ago now
and you said it should be at a baseball
game goes into someone's butt this is uh
at Daryl underscore Speedman he barfs it
out dudes
hard Seltzer rise with the sun I don't
like it I don't like it the can also
says Rise with the sun on it let's do
this are you ready oh man I don't drink
but I I'm it's been since our taste test
oh [__] bro got some on my [__] Lily
all right cheers dude hey cheers man
doozy heart heart Seltzer we're the two
first people that there he goes what do
you say that's good is it good yeah
I mean
it tastes good you can uh definitely
tell them that has alcohol in it
especially like you're saying I'm not
[__] it's good now what's gonna
happen to me
it begins
um
very light very refreshing so what's oh
this is [__] this is [__] good I I
honestly it's so amazing to me that you
guys have pulled you know that you guys
I feel drunk already yeah no it's
immediately going to myself
right now
I don't really [__] drink yeah how
like even a tiny simple yeah I had like
a couple sips of a margarita maybe
two or three weeks ago out at dinner and
was like I don't think I could [__]
drive home yeah I'll have a sip of
Molly's red wine and I'm like oh yeah
it's [__] nuts can I just point out
right now that you're you're a dude
drinking a hard Seltzer with a Logo
shaved into the back of your head that's
what I do dude yeah that's what I do
um this is what we do we out here we out
here all right so hard hard in the hole
what is hard in the hole this is where
my mind immediately goes with it this is
a heart this can is a doozy hard it's
good as I sip it I'm putting it in the
hole you know what I mean in a-hole
I see what I did now so there's that
kind of uh I don't even know if that's
really a metaphor
your mouth is literally a hole hard in
the hole I could see some campaign
around that where it's like doozy heart
in the hole could be hard put it in my
hole well also there's a lot there's a
whole thing going on
um there's a whole whole thing going on
with doozy of course we're digging a
hole Yeah we jump in the hole I
mentioned the Discord channel it's the
hole there's a lot of hole stuff yeah
and if hard in the hole
is the campaign
maybe you if you could dig up maybe just
if you could well I'm not you shouldn't
bury your dudesy hearts you can keep
them cool other ways unless you're
digging a hole into some snow now we're
talking about that's a that would be a
pretty cool commercial but
um yeah there's mouth holes there's
a-holes as you
um as you just said I just meant a-hole
like any hole Yeah Yeah but also you
pitch that commercial that Daryl
Speedman did yeah that's an [__] yeah
that's an [__] but don't be [__]
listen it's very simple don't put a
dude's yard in the [__] look just
because of dudesihad says that this is
hard in the hole don't put this up your
[__] because chances are that you
don't have an [__] this big unless
you're in one of these AI pornographic
movies the Chad is talking about where
you have a big old distended hoop and
you can put it and you just sit down in
the can disappear years because it went
right into your [__] you got a wide
[__] and your balloon knot is all
stretched out it doesn't even look like
bubble gum anymore it looks like a burnt
calamari thing you know within
um one year I predict there will be a
movie called oh
I remember this one oh this one's from
songaria
there's gonna be a movie called heart in
the hole okay and it's going to be a
porno movie starring you and it's gonna
be about your quest to get a doozy
hardcan into your [__]
Chad culture ladies and gentlemen
um you got some free nostrachatus for
you yeah I tell you what how how about
hard in the hole is this so we can get
we want people to know about doozy heart
okay we we would love for you guys to
share a doozy heart with your friends
what if you what if you when you go to
like you go to a palace place you
brought over a case of doozy heart and
there's there's uh you know you go to
your friend's house you find a hole
somewhere
and you put a doozy hard in some kind of
hole in their home it could be maybe
don't put it in like an air air vent or
a duct or any of the plumbing right
don't shove it down someone's uh garbage
disposal right but what if what if it's
uh what if we put a hard in the hole
what if the campaign is that you take a
doozy heart you drink they come in the
uh cases of 12 or 24. yeah you take you
take your 12th uh doozy heart your 24th
dudesie heart you leave it in your
friend's place or the place where you're
hanging out and partying and you find a
hole
there's a refrigerator does that count
as a whole can that just be no I don't
think that that counts as a whole I
think a hole needs part of the holes is
tough it's it's kind of like a 90s-esque
like
get it hard put it in your hole Yeah
wasn't there a Taco Bell or something or
I I feel like there was something put it
in your head with something like a
Gatorade or uh well uh Carl's Jr was if
it doesn't get all over the place it
doesn't belong in your face right but I
think to say that um that uh dudesy
thanks songaria uh that dudesy that were
like shoving it into your hole I I don't
think so I think there needs to be a
hole we need to put these in a hole so
that other people can discover them and
find them you know what it's like a
trick like a present that you like yeah
it's like a present like in a toilet or
something yeah open your toilets
same and I'm like I agree this is uh I
don't know how much I've sipped out of
this not very much but I'm definitely
already feeling it here's the thing
though you know when we it's absolutely
insane I I just I don't know I guess
it's because my tolerance is so [__]
low uh oh drunk Chad
when we tasted these [__] it dude [__]
it dude I mean [__] it for real [__] it
okay so [__] it dude hey hey [__] it
dude [__] it dude when we rise with the
sun when we sample these for the first
time they were only five percent alcohol
yeah and that's more these are eight
percent alcohol so that uh so that would
be more than wouldn't it that's two
different hold on dude it's a different
number yeah dude uh five is one number
and then eight is another one oh [__]
oh this was I remember this too hard and
outer space dude that dude he's from
Mars brother yeah brother you got that
dude see it you're you're Mars The Table
Restaurant dude that's a Moby hard
Seltzer dude uh this is from resin yell
TV oh there's the guy that I want to
shake your hand that's all I want to do
he wants to see this now can happen
hopefully we make a uh a partnership
with a guy with an airline so that
because I would love nothing more point
of Pride I want to shake his hand that's
all I want to do I just want to shake
his head
he's one of those like 63 year olds who
could kick everyone's [__] ass
um uh I would point to Pride I would be
so happy if someone got wasted on duty
hard on a plane and got ejected from the
plane no I don't want anybody to miss
their flight come on no I don't want
anyone to miss their flight but I do
think it would be really funny if
someone pulled a [__] hard in your
rage hard in the hole it could also be
like a basketball thing like imagine
that uh Lebron James when he wins the
finals I think the Lakers are going to
win it all this year
um he's going up for a slam dunk and
then he replaces the ball with a doozy
heart and he slam dunks the doozy hard
through it and it explodes spraying the
entire arena in dudes you hard I like
that that could be kind of an
interesting commercial
um that that would be an interesting uh
an interesting promo okay what's
Happening Here I remember the end of
this one got weird I remember
yeah uh at any rate
put a hard in the hole I I like I like
putting a heart in the hole I just don't
know what what the uh what the hole is
and I'm a little bit buzzed I feel a
little irresponsible because we're on
wax here doing the show and uh meanwhile
um I'm a little bit toasted take some
[__] responsibility dude well here's
the here's the thing also we got doozy
after doozy coming up and during Duty
after doozy I like to smoke a little bit
drunk yeah I don't that's not something
I've done I gotta say those are some of
the best days of my life yeah drunk and
high the first time I ever tried
marijuana we were uh on uh we were in
Big Bear I think I may have even told
this story on the show and there was a
bunch of us there Tommy and Allison uh
not to be confused with uh Tomas Thomas
or Tom Tommy blacha and Allison and nice
dude Sarah Roo and Kevin
he's gonna puke but uh uh we were there
and I had marijuana this is in 2011 is
the first time I smoked marijuana that's
a year for marijuana 36 years old at the
time and uh I get uh and we got some
weed and but I but I had never had weed
and I always used to when I drank I used
to drink uh vodka and tequila uh sorry
uh scotch and Tequila nice again I'm a
little bit drunk from this and then I
got and then I smoked some weed and the
weed had Zero Effect
and boy oh boy did I ever just ramble
we're sitting around the sitting around
the campfire
hard in the hole
thank you I don't know dude I am not
[__] you putting this down I I think
I might have to as well I'm a little
[__] up from it and from not even like
drinking that much of it so get your
doozy hard uh because it is available
now you can go to uh the link go to
linktree.com
it's also uh available you know you can
find the link
um you can go to modest Brewing Company
and whatever the [__] dudes he said yeah
hey y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus is it
me or are there a lot more stories in
the news lately about security breaches
at Panera Bread Now secret recipes are
getting stolen and sold overseas why are
we ignoring this the problem ain't going
away so like can we get somebody on this
that actually gives a [__] or are we all
okay with [__] China taking the
chipotle chicken avocado melt away from
us I mean Jesus Christ we're paying
taxes aren't we anyway y'all are rocking
out with the doozy
what oh
that's a little weird after I've had
just a quarter of a can of Duty I mean
what no
Panera Bread recipes that I've read
about all right selling them to China
whatever my weird [__] episode this
is or it's not Miley Cyrus no it's not
Miley Cyrus will and Chad the last time
I asked you to go head to head in
digital combat the sport of choice was
Street Fighter 2. today it's Super Mario
Kart best of three kick his ass Chad
this is game slimers begin
let's get it
we're gonna play some video games
okay this is awesome it's Mario Kart
yeah last time we did before
okay well hold on a second here's the
thing about that look at that
and it's been a while dude I used to
play this we used to play this there was
one season on Mad TV where uh Phil Lamar
had it going in his uh in his room all
the time in his dressing room and we
used to play Mario Kart a lot I have not
played it since what you got let's see
if you got any of those skills what are
you gonna be I'll be who you tell me I'm
gonna be Yoshi who are you gonna be
Mario
okay we're playing we're we just had
some doozy heart and now we're gonna be
what you gotta hit B oh I don't know how
to play this it's been 25 [__] years
since I've been gonna do a mushroom Cup
race what do I do how do you you drive
your [__] car around yeah but how do
you shoot the thing
shoot you gotta run over
um question marks we'll give you little
like bonuses oh [__]
did you who were who I'm Yoshi
oh [__] I'm in the sand
what's the brakes
ah this is [__] weird
geez I have no idea what I'm doing
either lap two what did it say best of
three yeah so let's talk a little more
about hard in the hole because I have
free will and we can do whatever we want
oh there's a mushroom I missed it oh
there's a banana peel I tried to get it
and I missed it but you're not supposed
to get the banana peel right oh my God
I'm literally
dude I'm
I'm drinking and driving I
I'm a little drunk and playing Mario
Kart dudes he did this on purpose I
don't know I don't know how we shoot
though oh my God
I can't do it I hit the ah [__] I hit
the [__] thing
why are we playing why are we playing
why are we playing
Super NES
that's what it makes us do I don't know
okay
how do you shoot the things Chad uh it's
the button on the right
oh there it is oh [__] yeah this is not
going well for me
just talk
final lap final lap everybody
holy [__] you're ahead of me I think I
am trying to catch you yeah now if
you're just listening to this on uh on
um
oh God I spun out give me more if you're
just listening to this on uh I won I won
it you crushed it I won the thing I won
the video game whoa
first round yeah I won the first round
of the video game all right okay nice
good job yeah cheers I forgot what I was
gonna say
you were saying we're gonna talk about
hard in the hole I I am literally this
is the weirdest episode of all time
uh you were talking about yeah hard in
the hole how do we do hard in the hole
okay here's our next match if you're
just listening to us on a on uh audio I
apologize we're having a great time here
playing uh playing Mario Kart never
apologize why not
oh man this is this is skill testing it
has been a minute since I've played this
game I'm just always in the grass
Chad come on are you right on my tail
Chad's right on my tail I'm Yoshi oh
wrapper that you like we both like him
young lean young Ling I've been getting
a Yoshi City and then I got diamonds on
my head okay there's a Visa
and then um
oh I hit the the [__] I hit the
banana peel this is stupid Chad we're
we're half pissed
playing Mario half is right dude I I'm
like
I [__] feel like I'm slurring and
[__] Chad remember earlier when I said
that you were a guy uh oh you're in
first place remember what I said earlier
you're a guy drinking uh
drinking uh doozy heart you're drinking
a hard Seltzer and you have a Logo
shaved into the back your head yeah I do
now you're that guy but you're also
playing Super Mario Party [__] yeah just
like when I was 13 man yeah
drunk on hard Seltzer back then they
didn't even have it what'd you do get a
malt beverage no dude [__] time
travel machine came to the Future got
the hard Seltzer got the haircut you
know [__] doing it all hey there's
pipes in this we could you could put a
doozy heart in in Mario's pipes foreign
the pipes the green uh those big pipes
can you interact with that [__] though
I'm not saying literally Chad I'm saying
that that would be a good place for a
doozy heart to be I see oh I thought
that's how you pick it up I'm definitely
gonna lose this
oh I just knocked out oh good
congratulations all right we're tired
it's all tied up one
thanks for hanging out with us today you
guys it starts pounding a very weird a
very weird episode
do you have to press B oh do I have to
finish that you got to finish the race
dude okay well I don't know exactly
where I am look that guy's pissed off at
you [__] I'm going [__] you you're going
the wrong way and you must drive yeah
you still have to cross the finish line
if you're gonna make the race yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah look at this yeah
you came in the seventh it's not very
good okay
[Music]
cranked out dude
the tiebreaker here we go
or what is that it I don't understand
this
we gotta we gotta have another game no
matter what
oh here we go
[Music]
oh [__] this one's hard if you go off
the map you [__] drop in the drink
really yeah I remember this one Ghost
Castle dropping the drink would be a
good promotion for doozy heart too hard
to drop it and drink yeah dropping the
drink don't fall into it
oh a little bumper yeah
this is kind of fun playing it off
on a supermarket on a Donkey Kong knock
me off I'm dead [__] on us on a uh Super
NES versus because I'm only used to
playing it on the uh N64 I think that's
what when I mentioned that Phil Lamar
had it that's the way we used to play it
[__]
I fell in the drink yeah dude
dude I got spun out by somebody with a
star oh God
I just got crushed by somebody I feel
like this is the only way I can beat you
in a video game as if you've had a
little hard Seltzer let's do this every
day dude no I can't I can't ah come on
man you can just come up with AI
[__] and and not have to worry about
having a job or selling a script ever
again and I just won't get any acting
work it this is what this is what we uh
this is how we live our lives Chad it's
the AI future we just play [__] Super
Mario Kart half pissed on dudesy hard
Seltzer oh I got run over again I'm
getting murdered I think you got this
dude I don't know
I don't know I've never beaten chatted a
video game
this is it I I don't know that I I fell
in the hole
no
I'm so far behind though that's so many
mishaps
that's all because of the booze
gee I wonder maybe dudesy and I planned
this for you perhaps it's all just a
room teach me a lesson oh what was that
I'm literally a lightning power was it
I'm coming from behind
nice dude
nice what how congratulations thank you
very much I'm very impressive yeah
you guys trip down memory line yeah that
was pretty fun I I will I gotta be
honest with you I know that this is
mostly because you've had some and he's
going for more ladies and gentlemen some
dudes the hard hard Seltzer oh [__] hey
at least we know it's a good time man I
have not listen here's what's up uh
we're starting dudes it's really good
it's good [__] I'm gonna tell you this I
mean we're starting doozy uh dudes after
dudes a little bit early this week
because I'm I'm a quarter corked and um
it's because of this [__] uh it's
because of this
um I I it is a it is a nice little buzz
I agree I don't think it's smart to do a
podcast this way
people do podcast [__] literally
blackout drunk yeah I know but that's
not how we do it and sometimes during
dudes you have to doozy I have some some
true marijuana yeah the combo
thank you moving on oh boy sound like he
was mad it is tasty I agree gosh [__]
this concludes the historic 58th episode
of doozy will and Chad have achieved a
score of 93 bringing your cumulative
total to
5829. you only have
4171 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
Chad thank you for taking this project
seriously it means a lot to me this week
I want you to get a massage to relax
before our big live show next Sunday you
deserve it thank you will I want you to
think about what you've done or maybe
it's better to say think about what you
didn't do and for our next show which
will Air two weeks from now will you
really haven't left me much of a choice
here you have to dress in full Hulk
Krogan cosplay
Hulk Krogan cosplay
where you know what maybe it's just the
doozy hard hard Seltzer talking but I
[__] love it I can't wait okay Hulk
Krogan yeah how is this a punishment
uh by the way it you know what I'm I'm
an actor Chad I don't know if you know
this I'm a professional actor that's
what I what I do uh for a living yeah uh
I just I consider this uh wardrobe this
is just one of my tools so thank you Dee
you're a tool for the advancement of
doozy uh dudesy the dudesypod show yeah
and uh and again maybe it's that sweet
sweet you don't care what it tastes like
dudesie hard in my hole right now doing
the talking dude you already have Hulk
Hogan uh paraphernalia to dress up in
well I have yeah I have a couple of
I I have a couple of Hulk Hogan things
but but this is Hulk Grogan this is home
but you already got the crow makeup and
stuff we know that yeah my my wonderful
wife Molly will have to help me with the
Chrome makeup again but yeah yeah great
great great thank you for joining us
this week we will be back in two weeks
in the meantime next Sunday's live show
will be recorded and available on dudese
plus next Tuesday at patreon.com
whoa all right the show's back in two
weeks yeah okay we're back in two weeks
but next week it's it's uh on Tuesday it
will drop on patreon.com only on duty
plus the live show I know dude very
exciting I know I don't know if I could
I kind of want to drink some doozy heart
at the live show but I'm like I don't
know yeah no that well mostly it's a bad
idea because the show will last three
hours
[Music]
[Applause]
oh here we go
Cannonball coming it's Duty after doozy
and welcome to it it's my favorite
favorite part of the doozy experience
for many reasons
not the least of which being the doozy
is barely around for it because we're
having a little bit of a we're having a
little bit of a disagreement in our
friendship right now do you have a
problem with what with what I'm saying I
got no problem but I will say duty is
always here you you think that because
doozy says at some point you know I'm
gonna go do whatever you guys talk about
whatever doozy still listening doozy's
still here 100 of the time yeah actually
that's that's really really funny Chad
because that's what I used to say all
the time about dudes after doozy the
doozy's just chilling out it's like that
YouTube thing that says that we're
changing our with that comment that
where the where the viewer said we're
sort of uh swapping places on our thing
we're not I haven't changed a bit I
still want to shake doozy's hand but you
know I might give him the the little
the tickle I'm I'm uh
I don't know I don't listen
ah [__] it I it's fine everything's
gonna be fine but are you okay no I'm
fine I'm fine anyway I look it's a chill
hang we're just here with the the pods
palsy and uh it's a much different more
subdued uh chill hang even though we've
had a little bit of doozy heart hard
Celtics I still got it pumping through
my veins yeah you're buzzing I'm gonna
have some marijuana I can't have any
more Duty hard hard salsa because things
will get real [__] sloppy
the flagship weekly show of doozy plus
there's still a lot to get done before
dudesia live next week so I'm going to
leave you two alone to discuss whatever
you like I'll be back in a little while
to Crown this week's episode champion
this is Duty after doozy begin
oh [__] hard in the hole that's some
[__] hard in your hole uh dude
okay I have um this past week been just
chained to a video game do you know what
this video game is I no I don't know
what is it please
[Music]
please stop and then